and I think it's great that women are
speaking out last week Harvey Weinstein
was accused of three decades of sexual
harassment by women in Hollywood actress
rashida Jones has never worked with
Weinstein but tells et she's proud women
are taking a stand I just hope that it
encourages a culture of continuing to
speak out because I think you know
sometimes these things peak and one
person kind of has to be held
accountable but there I'm sure there's
so many other instances of this in every
business really and I hope that it gives
women the backbone that they feel like
they need and the support that they need
to speak out et spoke with the actress
on Saturday at the Los Angeles dance
projects annual gala Natalie Portman's
husband Benjamin LPA is the
organization's artistic director you
guys rolled as a squad tonight he came
kinky okay you've got parishioner cog
you've got Natalie you've got Benjamin
how are you guys in car yeah yeah talk
to me about would you get ready together
we did we did we all got ready together
I was a little appalled when I was like
in the middle of getting my hair teased
and I turned around and like Baryshnikov
was behind me it was definitely
something I'll never forget your
friendship with Natalie you guys seem
like you're just kind of thick as
thieves you're having so much fun
together posing for photos yeah you know
we've known each other for a really long
time and she's just one of my favorite
people of all time she's such a good
friend and you know it's a this is a
weird town and like when you find your
people you got to keep on yeah yeah
tonight what are you expecting why are
you excited to be here
dance it's all about the dance I love
dance I can't do what they do and I feel
like Ben is such a huge asset to the
arts community in the city and I'm so
excited to see the performance I've seen
your videos on Instagram you can bust a
move is that the secret to this physique
yeah yeah that's it that's what's
happening under this muumuu is it is a
hip-hop based physique
[Music]